usted o alguien que conoce puede tener
una enfermedad pulmonar en curso este
video le mostrará Cómo una
rehabilitación pulmonar puede ayudarle a
vivir mejor con una enfermedad
pulmonar antes de comenzar su programa
su equipo de atención médica deberá
conocer su historia clínica por ejemplo
es posible que haya tenido problemas en
el corazón o en los vasos sanguíneos por
lo tanto evaluarán el fun de sus
pulmones en las pruebas de respiración
se medirá su nivel de inhalación y
exhalación o cuánto aire pueden retener
sus pulmones se puede realizar una
prueba de caminata de 6 minutos es
posible que examinen su ritmo cardíaco
presión arterial y nivel de oxígeno en
sangre su equipo médico utilizará su
historia clínica y los resultados de las
pruebas para diseñar su programa de
forma
personalizada su programa puede incluir
tres partes principales actividad física
educación y
asesoramiento con el tiempo la actividad
física puede hacer que sus pulmones y el
corazón funcionen
mejor además puede aumentar la cantidad
de tiempo durante el cual usted puede
realizar sus actividades diarias como el
trabajo las compras y la actividad
física si es adecuado para usted su
programa incluirá ejercicios aeróbicos
este tipo de ejercicio dificulta la
respiración y hace que su corazón lata
más
rápido además los ejercicios de
entrenamiento de fuerza pueden hacer que
sus músculos sean más fuertes y los
ejercicios de estiramiento pueden
mejorar su
flexibilidad la educación puede incluir
clases que le ayudarán a entender
controlar y afrontar su enfermedad
pulmonar estas clases le explicarán Cómo
funcionan los pulmones normalmente
también le explicarán cómo las
enfermedades como la enfermedad pulmonar
obstructiva Crónica o
EPOC afectan a sus
pulmones puede aprender dos maneras de
controlar la respiración en la
respiración con labios fruncidos inhala
lentamente por la nariz y exhala por la
boca con los labios
fruncidos en la respiración abdominal
entrena el músculo del diafragma para
que realice la mayoría del trabajo
respiratorio su equipo de atención
médica hablará con usted acerca de su
medicación y los cambios en su estilo de
vida se le mostrará Cómo usar el oxígeno
si está recibiendo esta terapia habla
con su médico si tiene preguntas acerca
de su medicación o si presenta efectos
secundarios es importante que tome su
medicación según las indicaciones de su
médico si usted fuma los cambios en el
estilo de vida incluirán un plan para
ayudarle a dejar de
fumar un experto en nutrición le ayudará
a crear un plan de alimentación si
necesita
aumentar o perder
peso también aprenderá Formas de
prevenir las infecciones respiratorias
tales como ciertos tipos de neumonía y
gripe mediante la
vacunación el equipo de atención médica
puede trabajar con usted para diseñar un
plan que le ayude a ahorrar energía esto
puede ayudarle a hacer más evitando el
exceso de
actividad su programa también puede
incluir
asesoramiento esto le ayudará a afrontar
la preocupación o la depresión que su
salud pulmonar le pueda generar después
de unos meses en el programa es posible
que reciba actividades físicas
adicionales y le realicen pruebas
pulmonares estas pruebas ayudarán a que
su equipo de atención médica sepa si
usted está alcanzando los objetivos del
programa los objetivos pueden incluir
mayor tolerancia para las actividades
diarias menos síntomas de la enfermedad
y habilidades de autocontrol y
superación